every time we have a thought we make a
chemical and and if you have
uh
an unlimited thought you will feel
unlimited and if you have a
self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and your brain instantaneously
fires circuits
that signal another part of the brain to
release peptides or chemical messengers
that signal hormonal centers
and when we get that arousal from the
thought that we think
those thoughts sometimes weaken the
response weakens the physical body so
it turns out that
the emotions that are created from the
thoughts are the signaling mechanisms of
the body thoughts of the language of the
brain
and feelings of the language of the body
and how we think and how we feel
creates our state of being